it is gonna be a busy weekend too let's
look outside it's so pretty out there
we've had just a few high clouds left
over from overnight clouds and they're
trying to get cleared out as the sun is
coming up in the East now we just have
some ribbons of mostly High thin cirrus
clouds out there and they'll keep moving
on and then we'll give way to a lot of
sunshine for the day so a good Sunny
Friday for us it is very chilly out
there we've got mostly 30s around the
valley this morning 28 out at Red Rock
23 up there at Kyle Canyon with a little
breeze and winds in the mountains today
could get up to about 25 miles an hour
look for highs only in the upper 30s and
Lee Canyon if you're headed up to ski or
snowboard a high of only about 30
degrees so it is going to be cold up
there 27 Indian Springs 20s for Caliente
freezing in Mesquite not much warmer in
Boulder City low 40s for Laughlin and
Pahrump you're below freezing this
morning with 20 up in Tonopah and mid
30s for Reno occasional clouds and we'll
get more clouds tonight and then through
the day tomorrow could get some sun in
the afternoon tomorrow are before the
storm arrives we're looking at rain
early Sunday before Daybreak through
Sunday evening could last into Sunday
night and Monday morning and Mountain
snow could see 6 to 12 inches of
Mountain snow this is going to be a good
storm and bring some good Valley rain
that we need Breezy to Gusty winds
though too and those could be a problem
if you're out on the road especially
open roads on the highways traveling in
or out of town so first it's a warm
front that brings a little warmer air
and that's going to tap into an
atmospheric River a lot of moisture out
in the Pacific and then colder air will
follow on Monday and next week so we'll
stay dry we'll stay pretty sunny today
just want to let you know there are
winter storm watches for our mountains
those are from 4 a.m Sunday to 10 p.m
Sunday night expect winter weather
driving conditions in the mountains snow
levels down to 5 000 feet through the
day but Sunday evening into Sunday night
those snow levels are going to lower
expected to be down to 3 500 feet that's
red rock level that's out there so it is
going to get lower might even see a mix
closer to West Valley neighborhoods
Monday morning of some rain and snow so
Sunday is the day that you could need to
do your indoor stuff get the indoor
decorating done start wrapping packages
and then Monday we'll see some rain
could last even until midday then some
clearing and then look at the sunshine
and cool temperatures highs in the 40's
lows in the 20s next week